you
the Honorable Kumar
bergna barricaded chairman of the
Norwegian Nobel Committee members of the
committee fellow Nobel laureates and
distinguished guests first of all allow
me to say that I am very pleased to be
able to join you in congratulating than
the region Nobel Committee on its
centennial I would also like to applaud
the Norwegian Nobel Committee for its
outstanding work it has accomplished
during the past 100 years I have nothing
but the highest praises for the
committee opportunity to speak before
you village podium the world has shown
great concern for peace but Jim location
of the century century there were more
the world
million people lost their lives 63
million people were civilians the 20th
century
was nationalism human experience even
today ideology conflicts between results
religions and cultures are occurring in
various places around the world
terrorists as can be seen in the case of
the u.s. attack are trying to justify
their attacks on religious grounds
ladies and gentlemen we are 21st century
will be a century the supreme test that
must be accomplished any cost the 21st
century into a peaceful
my ideas briefly on these issues the
world species second was the emergence
of agrarian civilizations 10,000 years
ago third was the birth of great
civilizations along the Nile the Tigris
Euphrates the Indus and the other rivers
some five to six thousand years ago
fourth was a revolution in thought that
took place in China India Greece in
Israel 2,500 years ago at the end of the
18th century for the emergence of modern
nations at the same time prepared the
way for full fledged nationalization
stronger people to not hesitate to
proceed toward aggressive nationalism
resorted to a strategy of defensive
nationalism confrontation between them
resulted in the tragedy the 20th century
the Industrial Revolution development
and create an affluence civilization
shadows the principal sacrifices weaker
people as well as the wars of
imperialism of stronger nations
globalization in the 21st century the
age of the information revolution
the third wave opens the door to the new
possibilities of knowledge-based
economies for nations and people are now
in the creation of industrial societies
which were dependent on the tangible
elements of land capital and labor
restrictions of time and space the
process of globalization is in
particular the establishment of the
World Trade Organization in 1995
globalization and greater wealth can be
create information capabilities are
overwhelming countries information
capabilities among nations created a
rapidly gulf between the rich and poor
if we ignore this between the advanced
and developing nations will be widened
further
as a means of inequality between the
rich and poor immediate punishment
against the gap between the rich is the
foundation
and conflicts the interests of all
nations must be respected we must
practice 21st century will be possible
and all of humankind will be safe and
happy must take the lead in such efforts
distinguished guests remnant of the Cold
War of the it's not only the 70 million
Korean people also directly linked to
peace and East Asia since I was
inaugurated president of the Republic of
Korea in 1998 pushed the sunshine policy
aims are preparing for eventual
unification but accomplishing
coexistence peaceful interaction between
supporting
chairman exchanges between the proceeded
only four days after the terrorist
inter-korean ministerial dogs were held
in Seoul and done agreements concerning
reunion reunions of separated families
the real inking of a view of the
International development's at the time
if you make our utmost efforts with
patience I believe there is no
alternative to the sunshine policy but
sunshine policy is a win-win policy that
contributes to peace here on safety I
hope that you will lend us distinguished
guests the 20th century was an age of
world wars however we have never given
up for peace after the first the League
of Nations was formed after second after
the Second World
the wishes and efforts of humanity
spreading the message that will define
the 21st century as an age of peace and
common prosperity of all humanity